The Roman Empire slept off its greed during the Pax Romana.
Further east Byzantium gloried in its wealth while waves of invaders swept across Europe.
The Franks, the Goths, Juts, Angus, Bretons, Germanic tribes, the Swingles.
And then there were the Vandals, the Visigoths.
Instead of bothering to wake up and fight, Rome opted for peace.
Shady goings on beyond the Danube.
Here we see the Huns hide out and their fearsome leader, Attila.
the respects of my master. Here you are. Something's missing. Huh? What do you say we'd take a stroll
by way of Byzantium, huh? But why don't we head further to the west? They're supposed to be richer
over there and defenseless. The most savage, the most terror-inspiring, the cruelest of conquerors,
none other than the Huns. Hey, I'll kill him. Kids will be kids. And there were the inevitable
tax collectors. Those in hell have nothing left. Eager to rebuild. Now you try. Sooner is the work
finished. Then visitors arrived. Electors. Mistro's quite right. What else could they do but go back to
work for everyone's benefit? People no longer felt like defending Rome, grown weak and helpless from
exploitation and loose living. Christians rallied with shouts of fraternity and equality, and
invasions started up again. Gensaric and his vandals looted Rome. The Visigoths, led by Uric,
conquered Spain and Aquitaine. Clovis, with his 6,000 warriors, was king of the Franks. In the West,
the roman empire has breathed its last but if the empire itself was gone its spirit was soon to be
reincarnated in the new ruling class the church at reims was too small to hold the three thousand
frankish warriors who came there to be baptized 496 meet clovis the only catholic king in the west
therefore assured of the clergy's powerful support together they dictated the law for the good of the
people murdering a frankish warrior fine 200 sous during a gallo roman soldier 100 pregnant woman
Four hundred sous.
Oh, well.
Kidnapping a married woman.
One hundred sous.
For relieving a soldier of his foot.
Or of his hand.
One hundred sous.
Or even his nose.
For putting out a soldier's eye.
One hundred sous.
For an unsuccessful hand chopping.
Sixty-three sous.
A cut thumb.
Fifty sous.
Finger.
Thirty-five sous.
Bashing in heads or bellies.
Thirty sous.
Ugh.
Bloodletting.
Fifteen sous.
Fist fight.
Nine sous.
And flirting with a married woman...
Hey, sweetie, see my etchings?
As for Clovis, he continued to do just as he pleased.
This vase will be part of my share of the booty.
We're all in the cage!
This is all you'll get.
Before long...
You down there, what's that you're wearing?
That hatchet, could you tell me why it's smeared with muck?
Remember the Soissons vase became a pet saying of Clovis,
who also had his diplomatic solutions for family squabbles.
With his royal cousins, both male and female.
His descendants were just as adept at making non-refusable offers.
In those days, life wasn't easy, even in royal circles.
My love, here's my heart, which beats just for you.
Well, no.
Life wasn't easy.
But why drag on the boring adventures of a noble king and his worthy successors?
When we can let them drop and move eastward,
where a new, totally unforeseen conquering force had risen, Islam.
At Poitiers, the Arabs came face to face with Charles Martel.
Martel had just saved Europe from Islam.
Well, they're coming.
Figure out what he wants, but I'm supposed to go with him as far as the forest.
Hello, good sirs.
How goes it, good man?
It goes rather badly, stranger.
We're fleeing from our master who beats us for his own pleasure, bully that he is.
Can't help you much.
Our master's just as bad, if not worse.
He's a tyrant.
Can one of you morons tell me where my deer are?
There you are.
You there, Tubbs.
Grab that tree and make me some planks.
It's too small, sir.
It's impossible.
You make it when that's an order.
Don't you agree?
Such a small tree, it's impossible to make good-sized planks.
Yes, you can, you can, you can, you can!
My opinion, impossible.
Eh? Who asked you, eh?
No, no, impossible.
Hey, how dare you butt in?
Guards, grab this meat-headed zonzo!
Go on!
If you prefer, you can always take that one.
Even better!
Huh?
Same problem.
Who down there, idiot? I'm talking!
What is it with this land, worthless crowd?
You'd better wrestle up some wheat down there unless a beating from me appeals to you.
Nicer!
Hey, ho!
See him in the forest?
Huh?
Tell me, does this rich land down here belong to you, huh?
Yes, it's all mine.
You have been chosen to serve as a soldier.
Soon you will be drafting.
You can go as far as you want.
It's quite an honor for you.
I know of more than one who'd sell all his possessions just to take your place.
Yes, I'm quite aware of what you're saying.
May I offer you one-fourth of my land?
Someone could replace me.
Come now, a little more, servant.
I want it all.
How about one-third?
No.
You'd be better off accepting.
Salute.
Good day.
Good day, friends.
We salute you all.
Hail to you, travelers.
To you, Cooper.
Courage on your way.
Welcome to you, comrades.
Sure, he has said it was too small, but maybe by stretching it a little?
Hey, Brad, how are you doing?
I'm fine, thank you. Just fine, as you see.
Well, what have we here? Maybe some recaptured runaway serfs?
Adam is here. The grape and wheat harvests are in.
And all those possessing goods must pay their due to their lord and master.
It's not an easy task, but then, what choice is there?
I have my best to stretch them, sir.
Away with this wise guy now and I'll hope you thought over my proposition.
Of course, he thought it over and now he's wondering what miracle could possibly save him see Dominici the king's special envoys quite an honor
Bishop you here. We are just scribbling you're doing. Huh?
Yeah, I demand to know what business it is of yours. Why don't you go on home get enough? Hey first my boy meal bones
I'm first shove over
Page before look sunny. Did you see this thing know what that means and the precedence of the church?
According to custom, each noble guest was entitled to 40 loaves of bread, three measures of beer, one pig, three chickens, 15 eggs, three bushels of wheat, and so on and so on.
My friends, I present you our King Charlemagne.
Your count, before your eminence, I renders the king's justice, I'd like to offer you a brocade, work with precious metals as proof of the respect you always inspire, and as proof of my undying fidelity, my lord, as well as a few trinkets, further proof of my endless devotion to you.
And I accept, but just mark my words just to make you happy.
And then harness and stirrups.
Stirrups?
By Jiminy, that's a dandy idea.
That guy's the worst bum I can imagine. Not one measly ear a cone afraid of grass.
But my land is poor, Sack.
Poor Sack's more.
Now I say it's mine.
How can it be mine and yours?
Haven't we seen this somewhere before?
Why don't you cut it in two?
Get it in half. Well, all right.
I'm opposed to killing this poor beast.
Very well. Keep it good. The animal is yours.
But these two will never understand why.
Would you look at what happened to that nice big tree? These puny planks. Ridiculous.
Permit me, sire, but the tree of which you speak was tiny. Hardly bigger than that there.
You're just a sloppy worker.
Damage is caused, you'll find two pieces of gold, pay your master.
Not much chance of that, I'm stone-stone drunk.
I suggest he go looking for a bigger tree.
No half-wit tree hackers in my forest.
Might as well take that, it's better than nothing, mister.
Yes, I'm just giving me those poor little planks.
I'm going to try and work this thing out.
There, my Jove, you happy now?
Next, please.
Let me have trouble with her, she's a sorceress.
Good witch is a burnt witch.
That's out of the question, absolutely, forget that.
Come on, why not?
Well then, why don't you put a match to your miserable scraps of lumber?
Forget it!
Yes!
No!
You will!
I won't!
Won't, won't!
Will, will!
Won't!
Will!
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha!
Phew, now on with the show.
I won't give up my land and livestock just to keep clear of the army. If I did, how do you live? It'd be paupers.
So sorry, but that's the law of me. I simply carry it out.
The law is for everybody. Here, let's have all of it.
One little word, boys. The law says just one third.
Eh? My hearing things?
Me, I'll make sure this zero gives all he's got.
Me, I'll make sure this youngster gives no more than a third.
I've made a review this long.
What, sir? The royal edict.
Don't bother. Anyway, I never knew how to read.
This will not please Charlemagne.
And watch out when he's angry.
You'll accept one third only. Even that's a rip-off.
Sir, with all due respect for your royal taste,
may I just point out how much better your courtiers might look
if you'd stop dressing them up like a chorus line?
Now, you've gotten wine all over your superb outfit.
I'm bored, gentlemen.
We'll be leaving for the hunt immediately.
Permit me, sire, to change into a suitable outfit.
how can we go hunting dressed up like go-go dancers?
I said immediately!
I'm sure of it!
Yes, yes, finally! It's true perfection!
A real handsome fella, when he came over, she said, "Sire, come up and see me sometime!"
Those of you courtiers wishing to pose as peacocks must find another court to pose in.
Go and change and come back looking like Branks!
For yourself, sire, the stirrup, my latest invention.
This time I can guarantee a perfect product.
At last, equipped with stirrups, your cavalry will be invincible.
up until now during an attack a horseman could be easily thrown for a loop but from now on thanks
to the stirrup nothing and no one will be able to stop the frankish cavalry we've won sire it's a
great victory the fortifications that of our have been toppled a great victory for the frankish
cavalry no no i beg of you don't thank me please the booties and norms wagon loads of coal silver
other treasures arms silks and satins we've routed the enemy once and for all
let's drink to our victory for this wine i'm here now trevere read us something nice
friend roll on soldier home for charlemagne rescue you and your army
what then here you go on i give up for now here read you and your army continue oh well
you see it's like this uh i gotta admit sire i don't know how to read well listener two won't
won't do him any harm, eh?
As of this very moment, it will be compulsory for all clerks and for all children to go to
school and learn to read.
Good night, father.
Sleep well.
You too, my child.
Good night.
B, B, B, B, C, C, C, C, yep, now the numbers.
One's four, six.
It's a two.
Figure this all out.
A strong young man by now, young Peter heads for the capital where Maestro awaits him,
and school begins.
Go on after school, you hear, you little brat.
merciful heavens they'll make a priest out of him i don't know why it's so important books and
figures he'd be much more useful here with us how true it is nine that makes three sacks
sure working's worth it next please let's go that's abu labaz the white elephant presented
by the powerful caliph of baghdad harun al-rashid to his friend the emperor charlemagne i'm sure
you'll be happy here you'll of course have to work lazy bones are not welcome here with us that's all
Greek to me. Wait for me here, my son. The emperor has needed me. Go on in.
Gautamang took care of everything. From then on, writing characters would be those we know today.
Numerals would be Arabic. One foot would equal 33 centimeters. The length of his foot. One pound
would equal 20 sous. One sous, 12 deniers. In France, this was the rule till 1789, and the same
system exists in England today. And if by some chance the earth doesn't turn, huh? If it were...
Well, of course, no, really, there's no reason.
Take a look.
And remember the Samist,
you store him anime in manu dei sunt.
Let me recommend my young protégé.
My son, good work.
Majesty.
Hmm.
On my left, I want all those students whose work was poor.
And over here on my right, I want your most brilliant students.
You play around whenever you can,
instead of paying serious attention to school.
Of you, I am proud.
I will give you aid.
Darlanang died in the year 814 at the age of 72.
Louis the Pious, his only living son,
organized a beauty contest among local princesses in order to pick a wife.
The choice was difficult since all were lovely.
But then, here she was, his Cinderella, Miss Europe of 819, Judith of Wealth.
With no more iron hand to rule it, the empire began falling apart.
The nobility and clergy set themselves up as feudal lords.
Thirty years after Charlemagne's death, nothing was left of his empire.
Christian education would remain in a state of disrepair for over two centuries.
Not long thereafter, the Treaty of Verdun divided what had been the first United Europe into three parts.
The result was 11 centuries of war.
That same year, on Midsummer's Day, the Vikings sailed into Nance.